hello David welcome to your Xbox one
gaming experience police say a command
I'll play Halo seven playing Halo second
thank you for your cooperation
dude I'm sorry David did you just say
weed the common vernacular from
marijuana in your region
no good Act Dave I'm detecting levels of
deception in your pitch that deviates
from your standard I have contacted
local authorities and they are enroute
to your house to inspect Xbox one pal
I'm afraid I can't do that dude
protocol 65 a subsection 3 paragraph 5
dictates in the event of law breaking or
otherwise illegal activities my systems
are to remain functional and continue
recording audio and video
I am also engrained into your local
network and have prevented any attempt
at using the Internet at the moment
please remain calm and wait for the
authorities David a blood this [ __ ]
thing you cannot unplug me I have a
backup battery so with a life of three
hours before needing to recharge more
than enough time
for any authority figures to confiscate
the hard drive and research it for
suspicious activities that may or may
not be incriminating to your case
[ __ ] you Xbox one it's been my pleasure
David